[Música]
y comenzamos nuestras secciones de
revista de prensa con rosa pérez masdéu
como todos los días rosa muy buen día
para usted feliz mañana de viernes vamos
a empezar a hablar de una de las
creaciones de la directora de 'russia
today'
hablamos de margaritas y niñas en la
televisión russia uno que ha circulado
mucho por redes sociales rosa y que
hemos conocido gracias al roston media
monitor y a la periodista julia davis
que ha pasado bueno buenos días raúl
exactamente esta periodista davis así
como el russian media monitor pues
siguen un poco cuál es la retórica en
los medios estatales rusos como
particularmente en este canal rusia 1
donde intervino como decías margarita
simonián la redactora jefe de rtp y ella
defendía que en estos momentos es
necesario subir la moral de la población
rusa y que para ello puede pues no estar
mal un poco de censura si te parece raúl
escuchemos a lo que dijo lo hemos
traducido al español
más fácil de comprender para toda
nuestra audiencia
hemos tenido dos periodos en nuestra
historia con muy poco o nada de censura
desde 1905 a 1917 y recordamos cómo
terminó y durante la perestroika y los
posteriores años 90 y también recordamos
cómo terminó termino con el colapso del
país
ninguna gran nación puede existir sin
control sobre la información los que nos
hicieron incluir en nuestra constitución
que la censura está prohibida sabían eso
muy bien
ellos que nos enseñaron durante décadas
no no no la sociedad debe ser libre una
economía desarrollada no puede existir
sin un sistema político desarrollado o
sin un sistema político libre todo esto
son falsedades
sólo hay que mirar a china les gusta la
economía china a mí me gusta y tienen
alguna libertad en el sistema político
de su país en el sistema informativo de
su país no no la tienen y nunca la
tuvieron quizás no sea algo malo quizá
sea algo bueno
bueno raúl ella dice no que ninguna gran
nación puede existir sin control de la
información veamos tampoco hay que ser
inocentes no ninguna gran potencia esa
es la panacea de la libertad de
información veamos el caso pues por
ejemplo de julian assange no que
enfrenta hasta 178 años de prisión por
cargos por violar supuestamente la ley
de espionaje si finalmente es
extraditado a eeuu pero bueno hay
niveles y niveles y por otro lado ella
lo que sorprende es que es responsable
de un medio de comunicación como tal no
así es rosa y hablando de censura de
mosquita y me acaba de anunciar que las
autoridades rusas bloquearon su página
web rusa exactamente vamos a
contextualizar de qué se trata
exactamente este caso porque el moscú
está ellos es un medio al que hacemos
mucha referencia aquí no pero este medio
a pesar de que tenía la sede en moscú
fue creado a principios de los años 90
por una ciudadano de países bajos y
tenía la intención de dirigirse a un
público de occidentales expatriados en
rusia tras el colapso de la unión
soviética bien este medio publicaba pues
como decíamos no
en moscú pero a principios del mes de
marzo tras la legislación aprobada en
rusia que persigue la difusión de
supuestas noticias falsas la redacción
de este medio de comunicación decidió
trasladarse a ámsterdam y por eso desde
ahí podían a continuar publicando con
mucha más libertad y llamar básicamente
a la guerra por su nombre pero hoy
publicaron pues la noticia de que la
reguladora de los medios de comunicación
de rusia el 'rosco' manssor pues les ha
bloqueado la página web en ruso a raíz
de un reportaje que publicaron el 4 de
abril sobre policías antidisturbios
rusos que habían sido enviados a ucrania
para combatir en la guerra y que se
negaban a hacerlo y que estaban
regresando pues a rusia sin embargo
recuerdan que la edición en inglés sigue
disponible que también se puede acceder
a la versión en ruso a través de una vpn
además nos recuerda esta información del
monstruo times que al menos 40 páginas
web nacionales e internacionales han
sido bloqueadas desde el inicio de la
guerra de rus en ucrania a la que se
añade recientemente según acabamos de
conocer el portal de nuestros compañeros
efe en el territorio ruso y bien también
señala esta información que muchos
medios independientes han suspendido las
operaciones por sí mismos como el de
nóvaya gazeta
tras ser amenazados por difundir
supuestamente noticias falsas noticias
que no se corresponden con la versión
oficial del kremlin y hablando de la
versión oficial de moscú como señala la
prensa pro kremlin y de hundimiento del
buque box va esto en el mar negro rosa
pues es lo que destacan es básicamente
en la versión oficial del ministerio de
defensa que insiste en que se produjo
una explosión dentro del buque porque se
prendieron detonaron las municiones que
se encontraban en el interior de esta
nave esto provocó un incendio que
desestabilizó pues este buque insignia
de rusia y que mientras lo estaba
remolcando para repararlo en algún
puerto pues que debido a una borrasca se
acabó de hundir por completo esta nave
rosa y cómo están nosotros en youtube
raúl queremos insistir en este millón de
gracias porque ya son un millón de
personas las que nos siguen en youtube y
queríamos agradecer no solo a ustedes
las personas que nos ven sino también a
nuestras compañeras paola y natalia las
encargadas de este éxito no claro que sí
en las redes sociales de nuestro canal
un millón de gracias como siempre por
preferirnos por vernos y buscar las
noticias internacionales por supuesto en
france 24 rosa gracias feliz fin de
semana sabemos el lunes con más de
revista de prensa pasamos a saludar en
maleza con todos los deportes